-You look great. It is good to see you again.
Since we've talked, "Army of Thieves," your movie,
is the number-one Netflix movie
in 90-plus countries, something crazy.
Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ] I mean...
-It's amazing. -I can tell --
-I can already tell you've changed a little bit.
This has gone to your head. The success has changed you.
-That's not true. But --
-Is anything different? -Oh, yeah.
Um -- [ Chuckles ]
When we arrived -- When I arrived last weekend in New York
and I stepped out of the plane and I went to immigration,
I met an officer, an immigration officer,
and he was the first guy I met in America.
And he was like, "Oh, my God.
Ludwig Dieter. 'Army of Thieves.'
That's amazing. Can we get a selfie?"
-Yeah.
-And I was like, "Of course, yes, sir.
Yes, let's do it. Let's do a selfie."
And then I asked, "Sir, but do I have to stand in this line,
or can I get through quickly?"
And he said, "No. No, boy. You go in line."
-Oh, wow. Wow.
So, for a second, you got a glimpse of ultimate -- Yeah.
I'm so happy you're here.
You know I'm a big fan, and you're super talented.
I follow you on all the socials,
and you post very funny, interesting things.
This is a photo you posted on Father's Day.
From your children. -Yeah.
-Look at this nice picture. They made you these homemade --
Can you tell everyone what this means?
-Okay, so, first I have to say
I love my kids, but now with that story --
So, this is me.
On Father's Day, my kids, they made me these beautiful medals.
-Aww. A medal for their dad.
-And look. That's so sweet.
The right one, it says "Happy Father's Day."
-Yeah.
-And the left one is, "You're ugly."
[ Laughter ]
I love my kids. It's so nice to have kids, huh?
It's so --
-At least they have senses of humor.
How old are they now? Your daughter's a teenager?
-Yeah, she's turning 14. And she's --
I mean, that's a pretty tough time.
She's, like, pre-puberty.
And even my boy, he's 8. Every day he --
When she starts to argue about anything,
he's just like... [Whispering] "Puberty, Dad."
[ Laughter ] -Your son says that?
-Yeah, my son. My son is, uh --
-Are they embarrassed by Dad at 8 years old?
No. The teenager is, right? -Yeah, the teenager girl.
She's embarrassed about anything.
-Yeah. -She's embarrassed about me.
"Dad, you're like --
You're a horrible person." For no reason.
-Yeah, a horrible person. For no reason.
-It's just like -- You're standing in the kitchen.
"Thank you. Good morning. Yeah."
-But they must see what you do and go like, "Dad's cool."
-You know -- No, the truth is -- I had a film in Germany --
For example, there was a poster, and I was naked on the poster.
And -- But the class of my daughter,
they had to go to a museum,
and so they walked past this poster.
And, you know, of me naked.
-No. -On the poster.
And the teacher -- a female teacher --
she was just like, "That's your dad."
"Yes. That's my dad."
-Yeah. "That's my dad right there." Yeah.
I heard that you brought a game for me tonight.
You know I love games. -That's true.
-What do we have in store? What do we have planned?
-Okay, so, I know you had -- Like, there have been
a few German-speaking actors, guests on the show.
-Yeah, of course.
-And they quizzed you on German words.
I would love to do the same. But because the movie --
I'm here for the movie "Swimmers,"
so I would love to do a quiz with you
about -- with German related to swimming.
German words related to swimming,
and you have to guess the meaning.
-"Swimmers" is the name of your film,
and so this is German words
that have something to do with swimming.
-Right. -I'm good at this.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. So, German word quiz.
Here's the first word. It's --
Do you want me to say it, like -- Can I say it fast?
-Yes. Can you say it fast?
-I mean the word. -Yeah.
-So, the first word is Beckenrandschwimmer.
[ Laughter ] It's hard.
Do you want me -- You know --
-Beckenrandschwimmer. He played Ross on "Friends."
[ Laughter ]
I know. I love that guy.
-Everything in German is dubbed,
so I do it with my dubbing voice.
Like -- Beckenrandschwimmer.
-Wow.
-So, does it mean, "A,"
someone who gets great joy from swimming
or, "B," someone who swims
by holding on to the edge of the pool?
-Say it again. -Beckenrandschwimmer.
♪ It's Beckenrandschwimmer ♪
-Ah.
♪ Beckenrandschwimmer, Beckenrandschwimmer ♪
-♪ Beckenrandschwimmer ♪
-They're not playing -- There's not music for this.
Beckenrandschwimmer. It sounds --
The way you said it sounded, like, nice.
So I would say --
-Someone who gets great joy from swimming?
-Yes, great joy from swimming, I say.
[ Buzzer ] -That's wrong.
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-There's a word for someone who swims and holds on to the edge?
What?! That's a thing?
-Yeah. -That's a word --
We don't have a word for that in America. Wow!
Beckenrandschwimmer. Okay. Alright.
-Next word is Schmetterlingsbeinschlag.
-It sounds dirty. -It's dirty.
It's, "A," butterfly kick,
or, "B," the spring on a diving board.
It's Schmetterlingsbeinschlag.
-Schbetter--
-♪ Schmetterlingsbeinschlag ♪ -♪ Schmettermelings-- ♪
-♪ Schmetterlingsbeinschlag ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Schmetterlingspraaang. Sproing!
-Schmetterlingsbeinschlag.
-Sproing! Sproing! Right?
It's not [speaking German gibberish]
-No. It's more like -- It's more like beinschlag.
-No, I think it's more like -- [speaking German gibberish]
I'm saying sproing, diving board.
[ Buzzer ] Okay. Alright.
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-Ah. Okay. So.
The last one, it's a little different.
Like, the English word for pool.
The German word for pool, yeah, is called "Becken."
And "Becken" has multiple meanings.
So, "Becken," does it mean, "A," pelvis and cymbals,
or uvula and bowling pin?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm gonna say uvula and bowling pin.
[ Buzzer ] What?! Are you kidding me?!
The -- What? How did you make that up?
Why would you make that up?
I didn't know what I was supposed to say.
I have no idea. We're not playing this game anymore.
-We will never play this game again.
-No, we'll play a game again, but not this one.
Please. Thank you. -That's for you. Thank you.
-Let's talk about your movie, "The Swimmers."
-Yes. -You play a coach.
[ Laughter ]
I love that you played this with me.
Do you swim in real life? Do you know these words?
-I can float and I can dive. I'm good at floating.
-But there's much more action in this movie. Yeah.
-I can swim. I can swim a bit. I'm not a really good swimmer,
but I look good standing in the ocean, in the water.
-Floating around. Yeah. Looking around.
How did you get the story for this script?
-This is a -- It's a true story.
In 2016, I met -- It's a film about two sisters,
and they flew the Syrian war, yeah?
And I met these girls in 2016 on an awards show.
I received an award as a director,
and I was super proud because it was my first award.
But then they came on stage
and received an award for being heroes
because they've been through this crazy journey.
And I was like...
[ Laughter ]
-"Here's my director award."
-"It's your award now." -Yeah, exactly.
-And I met the girls for the first time,
and I thought the story was amazing.
And five years later, Working Title,
Eric Fellner, called me and said, "Matthias, the producer,
we are doing this film called 'The Swimmers,'
based on the true story of these two swimming sisters.
And do you want to play the coach?"
And I was like, "Oh, my -- "Yes! Where do I need to sign?
Yes, I would love to do that film."
-The idea of the film is that the engine goes out on the boat.
-Yeah, yeah.
-So they actually swim and pull the boat.
-They pull the boat, and they save loads of people
by swimming through the Mediterranean Sea
at night just to save all these people's lives.
And they've been like 17 and 19 at the time.
-It's unbelievable.
It's an unbelievable, unbelievable film.
I'm so glad you made this. I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Matthias Schweighofer in "The Swimmers."
Take a look at this.
-I swim 200-meter freestyle in 2:12
and the 100-meter butterfly in 1:09.
-Butterfly in 1:09. -Yes.
-Is she kidding? -No, no.
She swims. She swims.
-Okay. Okay.
I have a small break before my 11:00 session,
so in the pool if you're quick.
-Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
-Okay.
-But I don't have swimsuit.
-You don't have a swimsuit?
-And goggles.
[ Conversing in foreign language ]
-Thank you so much. Thank you, thank you, thank you.
-Let's go.
-Hey, hey. Um, what's your name?
-Yusra Mardini.
-And I'm Sarah.
Who are you? -Sven.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Matthias Schweighofer.
"The Swimmers" is in select theaters Friday
and on Netflix November 23rd.
We have stand-up from comedian Kurt Braunohler
when we come back. Stick around, everybody.